S
SO MUCH FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>>> WELL, WE'RE SEEING
DEVASTATING IMAGES FROM THE
AFTERMATH OF HURRICANE IDA.
ONE OFFICIAL SAYS HALF OF THE
HOMES IN GRAND ISLE, LOUISIANA,
BARRIER ISLAND SOUTH OF NEW
ORLEANS, WERE COMPLETELY WIPED
AWAY.
HALF.
RIGHT NOW MORE THAN 985,000
HOUSEHOLDS ARE WITHOUT POWER.
MANY HOUSEHOLDS WITH MORE THAN
ONE PERSON, SO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
SOME PARTS OF THE STATE ARE
RUNNING OUT OF WATER, GAS,
MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
THE GOVERNOR TOLD THOSE WHO
EVACUATED TO STAY AWAY AS
TEMPERATURES COULD HIT TRIPLE
DIGITS TODAY.
OF COURSE, NO POWER, NO AIR
CONDITIONING.
CNN'S ED LAVANDERA IS AT A WATER
DISTRIBUTION CENTER IN LaPLACE,
LOUISIANA.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING THERE?
>> Reporter: THIS SITE OPENED A
FEW MINUTES AGO.
THE LINE HAS ALREADY WRAPPED
AROUND TO THE MAIN HIGHWAY.
YOU CAN SEE THE PILES OF BOTTLED
WATER THEY HAVE.
THESE LONG LINE OF CARS GOES OUT
INTO THE MAIN HIGHWAY AND WRAPS
AROUND.
THIS IS WHERE THEY'RE
DISTRIBUTING ALL SORTS OF OTHER
FOOD AND SUPPLIES TO WHOEVER
SHOWS UP HERE.
IT IS IN A STRIP CENTER HERE
THAT HAS BASICALLY JUST BEEN
RAVAGED BY THIS STORM.
I WAS TALKING WITH THIS LADY
HERE A SECOND AGO.
WE'LL CATCH UP WITH HER.
HER NAME IS EDIE.
WE'RE LIVE ON CNN.
WE GOT OUT OF THE LINE SO WE
WEREN'T HOLDING PEOPLE UP.
YOU WERE TELLING ME THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS HAVE BEEN PRETTY
ROUGH.
>> YEAH.
WE WON'T STAY FOR ANOTHER ONE.
IT TORE -- WELL, THE WHOLE
MASTER BEDROOM CEILING COLLAPSED
AND ALL THE WATER CAME POURING
IN.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE TARPS.
WE HAD A FIFTH-WHEEL TRAILER
PARKED IN THE DRIVEWAY.
IT LIFTED IT OFF THE JACKS AND
THE FRONT IS EMBEDDED IN THE
GROUND ABOUT A FOOT.
>> YOU'RE STAYING AT YOUR HOME?
>> YES.
WE HAVE A GENERATOR, THANK GOD.
WE MUST ON MASKS AND TRY TO
SHOVEL UP WHAT WE CAN.
>> WE'RE THREE DAYS INTO ALL
THIS.
I IMAGINE YOU'RE RUNNING LOW OF
SUPPLIES.
>> EXACTLY.
>> HOW WORRIED ARE YOU ABOUT THE
COMING DAYS AND HOW DIFFICULT
IT'S GOING TO BE, WAITING FOR
THE POWER TO COME ON?
>> I WORKED AT THE VA IN NEW
ORLEANS.
I'M WORRIED I WON'T HAVE GAS TO
GET INTO WORK.
THEY CANCELED THE CLINICS FOR
TODAY, SO IT'S OKAY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT I'LL BE ABLE
TO GET GAS TO GET INTO NEW
ORLEANS TO WORK.
>> I'VE SEEN THE LINES FOR THE
GAS ARE BRUTAL HERE IN LaPLACE.
>> IT'S CRAZY.
WE HAVE A BOAT, WE'VE BEEN
GETTING GASOLINES OUT OF THAT TO
GIVE TO RELATIVES TO RUN THEIR
GENERATORS.
>> ARE YOU STILL AMAZED AT HOW
MUCH DAX AND DESTRUCTION WAS
DONE?
>> WHEN WE GOT UP THE MORNING
AFTER IT CAME THROUGH, OUR HOUSE
HAS NEVER FLOODED.
WE HAD AN INCH IN THE GARAGE AND
IT WAS ALL THE WAY UP IN THE
FRONT DOOR.
TODAY IS THE FIRST DAY I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GET OUT.
WHERE WE ARE, IT FLOODS, THE
STREET FLOODS.
IT'S JUST CRAZY.
>> I IMAGINE BEING INSIDE YOUR
HOME WHEN THE ROOF STARTS
COLLAPSING AROUND YOU --
>> WE WERE TERRIFIED.
WE HAD A DOG IN THE BED UNDER
THE COVERS WHEN IT FELL IN.
WE DIDN'T KNOW.
WE HEARD ALL THIS NOISE.
WE TURNED AROUND AND THE CEILING
FELL IN.
SO MY SWEETIE WAS TRYING TO GET
THE DOG OUT OF THE BED WITH ALL
THE CEILING AND INSULATION ON
HER TO GET HER OUT.
JUST CRAZY.
>> YOU HANG IN THERE.
BEST OF LUCK.
TRY TO STAY AS CALM AS POSSIBLE.
>> WE WILL, OF COURSE.
>> GOOD TALKING TO YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME.
>> Reporter: JIM, THIS IS THE
SCENE THAT SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
DEALING WITH HERE, IS THE
REALITY AND THE DIFFICULTY OF
THIS SITUATION AND HOW THEY'RE
JUST NOW REALLY STARTING TO
SETTLE INTO IT.
90% OF THE TOWN OF LaPLACE IS
STILL WITHOUT POWER, AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS HERE ARE REALLY
PREPARING AND URGING RESIDENTS
TO BRACE THEMSELVES THAT THIS IS
GOING TO TAKE SEVERAL WEEKS TO
REPAIR.
IN FACT, THIS IS A CITY THAT HAS
TWO EXITS OFF OF INTERSTATE 10.
ONE OF THE EXITS IS SHUT DOWN.
IT'S STILL UNDER WATER.
THAT GIVES YOU A SENSE OF HOW
MUCH WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE HERE
TO GET THINGS BACK TO NORMAL,
JIM.
>> NO QUESTIONS.
SO MANY PEOPLE IN NEED.
ED LAVANDERA, THANK YOU.
>>> NEARLY ALL OF NEW ORLEANS IS
STILL WITHOUT POWER AFTER THIS.
JOINING ME NOW TO TALK ABOUT THE
AFTERMATH, NEW ORLEANS CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER JOSEPH GIORUSSO.
WE KNOW YOU HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO.
LET'S START ON THE ELECTRICITY
ISSUE, IF WE CAN.
HOW LONG BEFORE IT'S RESTORED?
>> ACTUALLY, THEY'VE ALREADY
STARTED TO RESTORING.
A SLIVER OF NEW ORLEANS EAST GOT
THE FIRST POWER TODAY.
SO THE ESTIMATED TIMELINE BY
ABOUT 24 HOURS.
OF COURSE, THE BIG QUESTION THEN
BECOMES, LET'S GREAT, HOW ARE WE
GOING TO PRIORITIZE THERE FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS, HOSPITALS,
NURSING HOMES, SEWAGE AND WATER
BOARD.
TYPICALLY WHAT HAPPENS, JIM, IS
EVERY PLACE THAT HAS THE LARGEST
GRID AMOUNT BY NUMBER OF PEOPLE
AND THE POPULATION IS GENERALLY
WHAT GETS POWERED NEXT.
OF COURSE, THE DISTRIBUTION
LINES, THE TRANSFORMERS BEING
DOWN WILL BE A VARIABLE THERE.
I'M ENCOURAGED BY THE FACT THAT
IT'S 24 HOURS IN ADVANCE.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO KNOW WHAT
DISCUSS THAT MEAN FOR MY
NEIGHBORHOOD.
>> WE'VE BEEN TALKING FOLKS
ABILITY WHAT THEY NEED IN NEW
ORLEANS.
I'LL PLAY SOME OF THEIR
COMM
COMMENTS.
I'M SURE YOU'VE HEARD SIMILAR.
HAVE A LISTEN.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION.
>> MY ROOF IN MY LIVING ROOM IS
CAVED IN.
WHEN IT RAINS, WE GET WATER
INSIDE THE HOUSE.
WE LAD TO MOVE ALL THE FURNITURE
OUT -- IT'S A FOUR-BEDROOM
HOUSE.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE LIVING IN TWO
BEDROOMS.
>> WHAT'S YOUR BIGGEST WORRY?
>> RUNNING OUT OF FOOD AND
BEVERAGES.
I HAVE A SON WITH MY HEART
CONDITION.
THAT'S MY BIGGEST CONCERN, IS
HIS.
>> THE BIGGEST FAILURE IS THE
FAIL U YOUR OF ENERGY
CORPORATION.
NINE PARISHES OR COUNTIES
WITHOUT POWER.
NINE?
REALLY?
>> LISTENING TO THAT ABOUT
POWER, IS THERE AN ISSUE WITH
THE GRID THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEALT WITH IN ADVANCE.
>> WE LOST EIGHT TRANSMISSIONS
LINES THAT POWER THE CITY.
THE QUESTION GOING FORWARD WILL
BE WHAT HAPPENED.
I'LL SAY THIS CLEARLY, OUR FIRST
PRIORITY AS CITY GOVERNMENT IS
GETTING THE POWER RESTORED.
THAT'S THE THING WE'RE ZOONTLY
TALKING TO ENERGY ABOUT.
WE'RE KEEPING THE PRESSURE ON SO
THE ENERGY GOES UP.
AFTER ALL THAT HAPPENS, THEN
WE'LL START MAKING ALL THE
NECESSARY INQUIRIES INTO WHAT
HAPPENED AND THE WHO, WHAT,
WHEN, WHERE, WHY AND HOW SO WE
CAN MAKE SURE TO AVOID THIS
SITUATION IN THE FUTURE AND BE
AS RESILIENT AS WE NEED TO BE.
>> I GET THAT.
BY THE WAY, SOME THINGS DID
WORK.
PREPARATIONS IN ADVANCE, LIKE
THE LEVEES HELD.
A LOT OF THAT WAS INVESTMENT
POST KATRINA TO KEEP THEM UP AND
RUNNING.
I WONDER, WAS THERE SOMETHING
RELATED TO ELECTRICITY THAT WAS
NOT TAKEN CARE OF AND HOW LONG
DO YOU THINK IT IS BEFORE THIS
IS RESOLVED?
>> WELL, JIM, I THINK IT'S TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS.
YOU JUST MENTIONED THE LEVEE
SYSTEM.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SPENT
$14.5 BILLION TO MAKE SURE ALL
THAT WAS STRENGTHENED.
THE LEVEES HELD.
I THINK THAT'S ABSOLUTELY THE
BEST NEWS POSSIBLE.
NOW THAT WE KNOW THAT THE LEVEES
HELD, THE QUESTIONS TURN TAO HOW
COME TELECOM DIDN'T WORK, HOW
COME DRAINAGE WASN'T QUITE
RIGHT.
HOW COME, MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE
POWER ISN'T RIGHT?
IN NEW ORLEANS WE HAVE A UNIQUE
SITUATION UNLIKE MANY OF THE
SURROUNDING AREAS.
WE HAVE FEMA MONEY FROM EARLIER,
WE HAVE A BOND ISSUANCE, WE'RE
GETTING ARP MONEY.
WE'LL GET ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
MONEY.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY NOT ONLY
TO BE ABLE TO DIAGNOSE WHAT WENT
WRONG HERE, BUT MUCH LIKE AFTER
WE REBUILT AFTER KATRINA, HOW DO
WE BUILD